eines der schwersten dinge beim erlernen
der deutschen sprache ist es die artikel
zu lernen
im deutschen gibt es drei artikel bzw 3
grammatische geschlechter der die und
dass die artikel muss man lernen um ein
wort richtig zu deklinieren und wenn man
ein wort ohne einen artikel lernt dann
hat man tatsächlich relativ lange
probleme ein wort in einem satz richtig
zu benutzen
viele von euch kennen das stehe ich auf
das straße auf die straße oder auf der
strasse welche muster gibt es also warum
heißt es der elefant aber die giraffe
und warum heißt es der junge aber das
mädchen gibt es da irgendeine logik wir
haben mal ein paar deutsche auf der
straße gefragt ob sie das erklären
können könnt ihr die artikel zu diesen
wörtern vorlesen
ja ok der elefant die giraffe das pferd
das pferd der junge das mädchen und der
junge das mädchen der elefant das pferd
und könnt ihr sollen deutsch lernen
erklären warum heißt es der elefant aber
die giraffe oder es schwierig also
elefant kann ich nicht so richtig
erklären aber giraffe okay ich habe auch
nicht erklären aber ich hätte jetzt
gedacht dass weil es auf endet aber
junge ende also keine ahnung also da
fragt man sich ja immer die regeln sind
ja irgendwie also wir die folgen ja
keinem schema ob ich also das hat
einfach ist halt so ich weiß nicht keine
ahnung
würdet ihr sagen es gibt ansonsten
irgendeine logik warum heißt es der
elefant und die giraffe oder die sonne
und der mond gute frage tat waren wir
mal so ich meine dreijährige
auch beizubringen keine logik habt ihr
irgendwelche tipps für menschen die
deutsch lernen wie man sich das merken
kann oder wie man das die geschichte
lernen kann nicht so wirklich also ich
finde es im deutschen ziemlich schwierig
ehrlich gesagt ich glaube dass wenn man
muttersprachler ist kann man das
schlecht das weiß man einfach keine
regel gibt es gibt tatsächlich für
manchen der regel zwischen mädchen also
alles ein ende
[Musik]
es gibt ein paar regeln findet also die
deutsche sprache zu lernen dass durch
das wissen auch alle die gerade deutsch
lernen wie ihr seht gibt es in der
deutschen sprache keine richtige logik
nicht mal deutsche können erklären warum
es der elefant heißt aber die giraffe es
gibt zwar regeln für einen teil der
artikel und darüber haben wir schon mal
ein video gemacht die könnt ihr hier mal
sehen und sie dann auch lernen
aber diese regeln betreffend eben nur
einen teil der deutschen normen und für
alle anderen müsst ihr wirklich die
geschlechter stumpf auswendig lernen
und weil das so schwierig und nervig ist
haben wir einen gender trainer
entwickelt in unserer website link der
euch helfen soll
und unser freund johnny und ich wir
zeigen euch jetzt mal wie das aussieht
ok jetzt sind wir in unserem studio und
wir zeigen euch jetzt den gender trainer
jeremy wird es hatte selbst gebaut und
wird es selbst testen bist du bereit ich
bin bereit
okay ich habe einige ich habe einige
wörter ausgewählt und die seht ihr jetzt
der abend die moglichkeit sehr gut dass
toten
du weißt alles war zu einfach die
ausstellung der kraft die entschuldigung
das hat einen regen dann machen wir was
das geschäft bin ich richtig
das geschäft der geschäft das geschäft
und jetzt seht ihr tatsächlich die regel
dazu ich habe eben gesagt dass es
manchmal regeln gibt und wenn es eine
regel gibt dann seht ihr die auch unter
dem wort sobald das wort falsch gemacht
wurde und die reviews genau du kannst es
zu den reviews hinzufügen
ich mach das mal für dich dann könnt ihr
nämlich das wort später noch mal üben
und bekommt die gleiche karte noch mal
in euren übungen
der freitag ist ein wochentag wochentage
sind immer der du weißt schon alle
regeln gibt es viele die arbeit der
elefant die elefanten und immer wenn ihr
ein wort falsch hab dann seht ihr noch
mal ein video von mir wie ich das wort
richtig sage mit dem richtigen artikel
ja ich muss rico vereins musst du wieder
holen nämlich das geschäft
[Musik]
ich habe es nicht gewöhnt geschäft ich
habe es gesagt das ist ja okay das
geschäft denn wörter mit ge sind
meistens das sehr gut gemacht 83 prozent
richtig herzlichen glückwunsch du bist
schon 83 prozent deutsch ja jetzt laden
wir euch ein den gender trainer einmal
selbst auszuprobieren
hier geht es direkt zu unserer apps viel
spaß damit und wir sehen uns am sonntag
schon wieder
bis bald
[Musik]